buckle up because we need to talk about
some recent news stories that are giving
us
the real life creeps
[Music]
murder hornets remember those things at
least three new specimens of the
so-called murder hornet
have buzzed into the pacific northwest
because we needed more things to just
flip you-know-what out and we actually
have one of them here now
please welcome murder hornet
[Applause]
i mean i have to say you're very stylish
murder hornet
oh thank you drew i mean you know i'm
always dressed to kill
oh murder hornet
what's the deal vile the murder
okay drew i mean i know it sounds really
bad
right but it's just nature
you know like birds gotta fly fish gotta
swim
murder hornets well drew we got a murder
so when i
bite the head off of an adult bee and
then bring his kids home
to feed my kids it's just the circle of
life
well can you redirect your murderous
energy to another activity i mean wait
hang on a second
what about the whole honey thing true
you bring up a good point but remember
honey is for the honey bees like that's
their
thing and they're so good at it right
because it's what they do
but your murder is what i do
as a murder hornet and so i have to go
in and annihilate a whole hive of
honeybees
in a matter of hours you know murder
hornet
is there anything else you like to do
besides murder
my god drew are you kidding me you think
i'm all just murder and no play
i have so many ways to live to kill time
i'm into watercolors
i actually just started skiing so fun
and
oh my god i just learned italian i'm
just starting out but wait
i learned this word this morning ready
that means murder good right well
i mean gosh i will say that
if you really just have to be around and
be another thing for us to question
mortality on a daily basis
you are really doing it in style thank
you
true we have fun just what's your advice
like when there's just so much to worry
about
you know what drew it's what i always
say just be glad
that i'm not murdering you i would never
i would never
well we have fun thank you murder hornet
for um stopping by
wait who are you gonna murder next i
would never
reveal that today
well all i can say is that i wish you a
very happy life
because you're kind of like you know
killing the rest of us
true you you kill me just kidding i'm
killing you just kidding again all right
thank you so much drew well thank you
murder hornet thank you so much
[Music]